In the video about the second law of thermodynamics
I talked about how entropy
in the universe is constantly increasing
and will not be reduced.
In other words, the energy
in the universe comes to entropy,
becomes less and less useful.
Proof of this even in our everyday life is, for example,
that while I make this video, my body
produces heat and this heat leads to entropy,
leads to more entropy in the universe.
The logical question is "How does heat lead to entropy?".
Remember, heat is a transfer of thermal energy.
Entropy is a state of the system,
number of states,
the amount of disarray we have,
the number of states the system can accept.
Let's give an example. Let's say it is
an ideal closed system, this little white square here.
These molecules move at a certain temperature,
have average kinetic energy,
but each molecule will do something different. I always draw molecules
with kinetic energy in the forward motion, but they can rotate,
to tremble and do anything else.
They can do different things,
but the kinetic energy in the forward motion is
slightly easier to label.
Now let's put some heat into the system.
We have a transfer of thermal energy, which we call heat.
Let me choose a color, I will use orange and
the letter Q to indicate the heat.
We have heat transfer to the system.
Because of this the temperature of this system
rises, the average kinetic energy increases.
These things start bouncing with a bigger impulse
and at a higher speed.
Why does entropy exist in this system?
We can say that both systems
have the same number of molecules,
we also have the same volume.
Here we see the systems in two dimensions and they seem to have only an area,
but we can imagine that they have and
equal volume. There seems to be two systems
the same number of places that molecules can hold.
But the state is not determined only by the projections,
which may be different particles in the system.
The state is everything in the system,
which can be used to predict what will be next
something that will happen to the system. Status includes and
the different speeds of these particles.
When we have a higher temperature,
we have a greater number of possible speeds.
Also, when we have this higher kinetic energy -
Remember all these molecules in the end
consist of atoms that have nuclei
and electrons that rotate around the nuclei.
And if they do not have big kinetic energy,
the atoms will not be able to get very close together.
Let's say these are the external electrons of an atom,
and that
is another atom.
If they had not very high kinetic energy,
if they have not very high kinetic energy,
may
are able to get closer to this position.
But if they ran and hit
much faster, they can get closer.
They can flatten one another.
If you imagine two balls that hit one another,
if they hit much faster, each will exert more pressure
on the other. So there is a bigger one
number of possible states,
when we have higher kinetic energy.
These two atoms have struck
at a high speed and "flattened" one another,
while these were good and educated
and they met with nice moderate speed.
We can have even more positional states,
more different configurations in three-dimensional space.
That's why heat leads to entropy.
I know what you're saying now,
"The heat does not only cause chaos,
heat can also be used to work. "
This is the basis, this is part of the foundation
of the Industrial Revolution,
steam engines, internal combustion engines -
the internal combustion engine in your car uses heat,
uses a flame reaction, the burning gases are expanded
and push a piston that is used to work.
This, of course, is true.
Here we have an example.
I have a few molecules that are driving around
with a certain temperature. Then
will add some heat to the system.
Add heat to the system.
In this system I have no boundaries.
Molecules can move here,
to accept different states, etc.,
but they can also expand the court.
What we see here is that the molecules push the plunger.
Push the plunger up, ie. we have a job.
I will color the work in another color.
We have a job.
I'll make the arrow smaller.
Here we have a job.
How is this work done?
All these things are jumping around,
we talk about many molecules.
From time to time some of these molecules
I'll hit here and bounce.
This will provide strength to many
a short time that will push the piston gently.
But we have many molecules.
I've just painted some of them,
but in any real thermodynamic system we talk
for millions, millions and millions of molecules.
We are talking about number of molecules,
the number of Avogadro.
So at any moment, many will
are pushed out of the piston, will
do the work, push and go
will move the piston in the direction
of power or of part of its power,
will push this plunger up and work.
We can say no heat engine
or system can not be 100% effective.
Part of the heat can be used to perform work,
but much of it will be used to increase the disorder
in the system, to increase the number of states,
which the system can accept.
One way of explaining that always helps me is that
heat is a heat transfer,
which happens at the boundaries of the system.
The heat can
to come from a flame down here.
And if the system was not completely closed,
he could at his borders
to give heat.
But inside the system, heat only leads to
increasing heat, which leads to increased entropy.
Work is also done at the boundary of the system.
There may be some released heat here,
who can also work.
The heat and the work are on
the limits of the system, but much of that energy
reaches the inside of the system.
And here the situation looks like a pog,
these molecules will hit each other much faster,
in many more states than they can take.
Another example is that when
move and walk on the floor,
only carpet friction will create heat.
It will contribute to entropy in the universe.
Even my very existence, the cellular processes in my body,
which create warmth, increase entropy
in the universe and make the total energy in the universe
less useful.